the war in ukraine has triggered a
seismic shift in politics with
far-reaching international repercussions
german economics minister robert hobbick
whose mission was to help germany go
green heads to the middle east seeking
new sources of fossil fuels a u.s
president who wanted to take care of the
home front travels to europe looking to
shore up a united front with eu and nato
allies can either deliver results that
help stem the conflict and its effects
we're asking biden versus putin can the
u.s stop the war in ukraine
[Music]
welcome to to the point it is a great
pleasure to greet our guests soraya
sahari nelson is talk show host at the
common ground berlin podcast and former
correspondent for the u.s broadcaster
npr
michael tuman is diplomatic
correspondent at the german weekly site
and it's a great pleasure to welcome
back to the show my colleague roman
goncharef he is a ukrainian by birth and
works with dw's russian language service
in bonn
and i'd like to begin uh if i may with
you soraya
following the trump presidency and the
disastrous u.s exit from afghanistan
many people doubted
whether there was still any will on the
part of the u.s to lead
is that different now would you say that
u.s president biden is right when he
says the u.s is back
well uh the u.s may be back or at least
the will but he certainly is not
benefiting in the numbers or in the
polls
in terms of his
the support that he's getting from the
american public i mean i think there's
there's still a lot of doubt about
whether he can
manage this crisis i mean and that is
what the americans are saying and the
fact that he's having that kind of
difficulty in the u.s sort of begs the
question what's it going to be like in
europe over these next days as he's
meeting with leaders here
and michelle as as diplomatic
correspondent how would you describe
biden's mission on this trip to europe
what can he accomplish and what does he
need to accomplish
well i think he needs to
come up with uh with a response together
with the europeans and that is the
challenge with the response to the ever
more
brutal war going on in ukraine and uh
responds also to possible war crimes
uh to the expulsion of uh
whole parts of big cities in ukraine
um and of course they will have to
deal also with the
very latest challenges um
for european unity and american unity as
far as gas and all deliveries are
concerned so holding the whole club
together that will be the main challenge
over the next 48 hours in fact we've
seen a remarkable degree of western
unity do you think that is now waning
well i i don't see it uh it yet because
uh we have of course peculiarities like
victor orban prime minister of hungary
who always begs to be a bit different
but then we see finally when it comes
down to the final vote he is he falls in
line and
um so i don't see the the the unity
crumbling yet but
it it might come further down the road
roman and excuse me i mispronounced your
last name uh when i introduce you but
let me ask you this um many observers
have said from the beginning that this
conflict is really about russia versus
the u.s would you say that that is right
and if so what could biden actually do
to change russia's calculus
well i would disagree i think it's a
it's a conflict between russia and the
west the west
as a civilization and the west as uh as
a system political system
um and uh economic system and um this is
how russia is has been seeing this
conflict for years and years so it's not
actually new the west refused to see it
like that the west has been looking at
it as a conflict between russia and
ukraine
which is just a battlefield um
and i think to your question uh how
could the u.s
maybe stop it i think
looking back
some weeks maybe months
prior to this conflict we've seen how
the u.s administration reacted
differently they disclosed their
information that they had about this
plan of this war
this was new and this allowed the us and
its allies uk and some other nato
countries to supply ukraine with weapons
and that was very very important for
ukraine because
uh it is um it's those weapons that
ukraine received in in the couple of
weeks before the war from the west that
enabled ukraine to stand firm
without those weapons i'm sure russia
would have seized a much bigger
territory of ukraine by now so i think
the past for the coming days and weeks
is to continue in that direction and i
want more weapons for ukraine exactly
and i want to pick up on that point in
just a moment it's become commonplace to
say that vladimir putin underestimated
the west but the reverse is also true
long is the list of political leaders
who clung to the belief that putin would
act rationally and avoid dragging russia
and ukraine into a ruinous war and joe
biden was amongst them
when u.s president joe biden and
vladimir putin shook hands in geneva
last june the russian president had
already started massing his troops on
the border with eastern ukraine
putin's words from back then now sound
like mockery
the leaders of two countries
of two main nuclear powers
are meeting to make the world safe
stable
and prosperous
a home for all the people on our planet
eight months later putin invaded ukraine
and biden responded with sanctions putin
is the aggressor
putin chose this war
and now he and his country will bear the
consequences
the west wants to divide our society by
speculating on military losses
on the socio-economic consequences of
sanctions
and it is using its fifth column to
achieve a goal the goal is to destroy
russia
has the war in ukraine irreparably
destroyed biden and putin's relationship
[Music]
and let me pass that question straight
on to soraya with the additional
question
do personal relationships actually
matter it's often been said that barack
obama made an enormous uh mistake
vis-a-vis putin when he referred to
russia for example as a regional
power
but do you think it matters these words
that are tossed around killer war
criminal and and and so on well i think
it definitely matters certainly it
matters for vladimir putin um you know
he
he's in a very bad spot right now at
this stage i mean he i think he's
surprised or shocked as perhaps we are
you know with with what's been happening
in ukraine the fact that there's been so
much uh pushback and he has no choice
and i don't think he would
i don't think he's going to trust joe
biden again and i don't see how joe
biden changes his tone or tune either i
mean it is interesting in the united
states that the republicans are now
slowly starting to be very uh vehemently
anti-putin and they're starting to say
things but the question becomes again if
this war does end and somehow putin
remains in power you know what what is
that relationship going to be like
post this i i don't know how they come
back from this i think it's as runes as
the ground in ukraine the thing is
though
donald trump idolized vladimir putin he
has a a weakness as we know for strong
men but that didn't change anything did
it the fact that he showed putin respect
uh well it didn't except that a lot of
the situation that we're seeing now is a
result of the u.s not taking this
seriously and europeans not taking this
seriously i mean it's not just trump we
can go back to the sbd in germany and
look at the relationship of various
leaders including uh former chancellor
gerhard schroeder and what impact that's
had i mean you know russia has had a
long time to to get to this point to be
able to launch this invasion
michelle we're in on the same point uh
if you would as soraya just mentioned
we've also seen a lot of german leaders
trying to cultivate dialogue with putin
including the current chancellor olaf
schultz did any of that help to moderate
his actions
no it did not this policy has clearly
failed and um i think it's it's striking
to see how
right after 2014 which was basically
everybody's talking about a wake-up call
right now i think we have the
catastrophe unfolding before our eyes
but the wake-up call was definitely in
2014
but they didn't draw the right
conclusions and
it it happened right after 2014 and 15
uh that the social democrats in germany
invented uh north stream 2 together with
gus prom and the gas pipeline that
brought
would bring gas directly into germany
from russia exactly and circumventing
ukraine and so and that basically was
all done after uh after the annexation
of crimea and the problem is that
they all thought and there were a lot of
leaders in europe and of course you
mentioned donald trump who thought we
could somehow do business with vladimir
putin but what we did not see and what
they did not see was the steady
incremental radicalization
of putin's nationalism which he had
adopted in 2011-12
as an ideology to keep russia under
control
roman
biden has long had quite good relations
with ukraine and in fact when he was
vice president in the administration of
barack obama he gave his blessing to u.s
military training for ukrainian forces
has that made a difference is that one
reason why we're seeing those forces
really able to hold off or even push
back the russians
well first
if i may just to remark to what soraya
has just said um i i do not think that
personal relations between putin and
biden
matter uh in this conflict uh of course
they are important but i think they are
overestimated because for russia there
is so much at stake
as i've said russia sees itself in a in
a almost biblical struggle with the west
uh so they would have invaded ukraine no
matter what the name of the u.s
president is
just to remind you obama was very soft
on putin
2009 uh the reset policy after the war
in georgia so obama was very respectful
uh to putin
it didn't stop the russian president
from planning this war and and i'm sure
this war has been planned for many many
years so coming back to your question
about biden in ukraine yes he has a
special relations to a relation to
ukraine he's um the first u.s president
who knows
ukraine very well as a vice president
during the obama years and
he was
supporting ukraine militarily
for the past years but it was the trump
administration that actually started to
arm ukraine in 2018 we have to remember
that
thank you very much
soraya during the troop buildup in
january and february and uh we heard
this mentioned earlier biden repeatedly
warned that the u.s did believe a
full-scale invasion was in the offing
and in fact they provided intelligence
information on that at the same time
president biden made it clear that there
would be no u.s boots on the ground and
no u.s planes in the air was he right to
rule that out so firmly in advance
and is the u.s do you think doing enough
to support ukraine now
well i think it's a very dangerous dance
on a tightrope that that uh president
biden that nato that the west is having
to do here i mean i think it was the
correct thing to do because um i
agree to disagree with with roman but i
do think that um
that basically the landscape was set for
you know by the way by the softness of
western actions for putin to do what he
did i mean i i don't think he would have
invaded no matter what so i don't think
that you know and you have to be careful
the man has his hand on the button i
mean what if he were to launch chemical
or biological or nuclear weapons in
response because he feels he has no way
out you can't corner him you know to
that extent because we just don't know
what he's capable of and so i think that
that was necessary for those statements
to be made and for them to continue to
be made uh it's a very fine line as to
how much support we can give but i think
we have seen a ratcheting up and we have
seen the u.s starting to deliver
more
but they just have to be very careful
not to cross that line and i think it's
it's really difficult for president
biden to to walk that line and to
continue to walk that line let me ask
you michelle about that line we're
hearing
some people would say rather hair
splitting discussions both in the u.s
and here about offensive versus
defensive weapons and whether they could
be delivered to ukraine about whether
particular types of weapons and systems
are possibly would be considered a
provocation or whether they in fact
would be a legitimate form
of support
does all of that make sense is it
commensurate with modern warfare and
beyond that is it
can we be sure that putin actually
thinks in the same categories that we do
well he openly said that he sees the
western arms deliveries to ukraine as a
kind of intervention by international
law it has not and russia has intervened
in the same
same way in many other conflicts so has
the u.s
but what is i think important here is
the the question what what kind of
weapons
might stop him or what kind of
deliveries are
sensible and which are not i think
the weapons ukraine is getting right now
have proved very effective
the anti-tank and
anti-air missiles and and uh weapons
they got from uh allies western allies
and uh also from germany uh after after
all after a long time of decision-making
and um are
very effective so are the turkish drones
the biroktar drones
and what would be entirely ineffective
uh is a no-flight zone for example
simply because what the russians are
doing now they are firing cruise
missiles from the caspian sea they are
firing from inside russia they can
actually do the same as the u.s is doing
over many hundreds of kilometers so a fl
no flight zone if you extend it to
ukraine you have to extend it actually
over great parts of russia
if you don't do it it's ineffective and
so if you're not ready to do that then
don't start with it
roman the war is currently at a
stalemate in fact there's more and more
talk
of a potential victory for ukraine what
does that mean for negotiations to
resolve the conflict and do you think
there is a role in talks for president
biden
of course there is um i wouldn't say
that we can talk of ukrainian victory at
this moment
it's too early
and
russia is definitely waging a long-term
war so it will continue for months i
think i think at least
and of course there is a role for the
u.s for the biden administration ukraine
has been asking
since we have uh no normandy format
anymore we don't have the minsk
agreement about the eastern ukraine uh
these formats are dead uh since russia
has invaded ukraine so we will have to
establish a new format so far we have
seen talks direct talks between russia
and ukraine but i think when we come
closer to a a real solution of the
problem a ceasefire and an agreement
then there will be of course
a place for the us at the table
more even more i think without the eos
no agreement can be reached
are we seeing any progress in any of
these other diplomatic channels whether
it's the talks in belarus the talks that
have been held
in turkey
do you really see any signs of true
progress
no not at all i'm very pessimistic about
those talks it's important that they
talk
one thing that can come out of it are
the humanitarian corridors the so-called
corridors uh which actually
uh do not work so far as they should be
but there are some and and people's
lives are saved so we should we should
continue in that direction but um as far
as the ceasefire is concerned i think
russia has no interest at all
uh to stop fighting uh to stop at this
moment um russia is getting ready for a
longer war and uh ukraine is desperately
trying to negotiate a ceasefire but i
think the chances are
very little
michelle
weigh in on the same question if you
would please do you think that biden
could open a channel potentially
directly to president putin putin has so
far refused to negotiate directly with
the ukrainian president uh solenski
yeah well i think uh biden could of
course um i mean he's done so before
and i'm i i think also putin would would
speak to him but i think to know veil
because basically and here i agree uh
with uh roman that
indeed putin wants to bring this war to
the end i think it is his mission it is
what he deems in his historical position
in uh
on on
the same pedestal like with peter the
great and joseph starlin
as the big conqueror and
that he wants to bring it to an end and
i think it's very difficult to stop him
and that is also why he doesn't want to
talk to zielinski despite all the
problems the russian army is having
and they could definitely need a
breathing
some breathing space now but putin is
not willing to give it because simply he
wants to his personal popularity his
position in history in russia
is dependent on a successful end of this
war from his point of view
saraya let's come back to
the question of biden's mission
both in shoring up western unity and
also pushing back
harder against putin the u.s recently
stopped its imports of russian oil would
you be expecting president biden to be
putting pressure on eu
and nato allies now to do the same
i don't think he's going to push i mean
i think what he's going to understand is
more beneficial is to try and find
alternatives and and to help europe's
overcome uh their dependency on your
european countries overcome their
dependency on russian oil and gas you
can't just
send the economies of the your western
allies into a tailspin which is what's
basically gonna happen if you just shut
everything down and so i think that he
and he's his people have talked about
this as he was boarding planes you know
i think that there is going to be some
attempt to try and address uh the
shortage that is going to ensue from
moving away from
uh you know russian oil and gas and so i
think that's his mission but i also
think this is a really important time
for him to sort of
give basically make nato more of a
european function you know he should
maybe be talking to them about making a
uh having a european commander for the
uh supreme or for the forces within nato
and also uh in basically reinforcing the
idea of a european defense fund that
sort of thing i mean he has to show that
kind of support i think that is going to
work more effectively than strong arming
because the u.s has lost so much
credibility
not just because of trump but even
during obama's time and i don't think
that you come in and you strong arm
again that that's really going to
basically get
the europeans to do anything frankly at
this stage let's talk about uh energy
because in fact the conflict in ukraine
is concentrating minds when it comes to
energy independence overall the eu
depends on russia for around 40 percent
of the natural gas that warms homes and
fuels power stations weaning economies
off those imports has become an urgent
albeit uncomfortable mission for
politicians like germany's economics and
climate minister robert habeck he is a
green party politician dedicated to deep
carbonization but he wound up rushing
off to the middle east to negotiate the
purchase of liquefied natural gas as a
substitute for russian imports one
slight consolation his new partner's
interest in also supplying green
hydrogen which eventually could replace
fossil fuels
michelle russia has just announced
interesting timing that unfriendly
countries as it calls them including of
germany will in future have to pay
rubles for gas deliveries that would
directly undermine western sanctions
against russia's central bank is this
the long dreaded embargo coming in
through the back door
yeah well it's a pretty typical tactic
of putin he so
what he does is he wouldn't block
oil exports
he wouldn't put a direct embargo but he
would leave the choice uh to the west
and it's basically then now you can
choose between bad and words and it's
your self-inflicted woos
you're facing there basically what it
means to pay in rubles is uh yes it's
undermining the sanctions uh western
countries would have to buy
rubles with uh
from the russian central bank which is
under sanctions do you think they do it
or is that the point at which they say
okay we're ready to forgo i i don't i
don't think they will uh do it because
basically this would then what we talked
about before this would then actually be
the final crack in all the the big crack
in the western unity and i think also
the german government would not i'd be
very surprised if they bought rubles all
of a sudden and this is what putin wants
to this is basically the choice putin
presents to them that you have to submit
and buy rubles in order to get oil and
gas so i think we are entering here a
phase and first they will probably go on
just because putin is clearly in breach
of the contract and he shows here that
all everybody who says well the soviet
union has been always been a reliable
supplier putin is not and he's not been
since 2006.
and so are you racing i'm sorry i'm just
going to jump
we don't have a lot of time left on the
clock are you expecting a cutoff of this
is what i i'm saying we are yes we are
entering a phase here and at the end of
this phase there will be a cutoff of
russian gas deliveries to europe roman
president zielinski sent a remarkable
video message directly to the germans
saying their gas imports feed putin's
war machine is he right and is it simply
time now for that door to be shut
well yes he's right uh germany has made
big mistakes importing russian gas and i
think it's time for an embargo i think
it will it will be coming in the in the
weeks ahead we've lost the initiative to
putin but now it's time to move on
soraya could germany handle the hit to
its economy to jobs uh we heard the
chancellor warning in pretty dire
terms
i think i think so just because there is
a still a reserve that allows this
winter to be passed so but they'll just
have to expedite their
finding other sources for lng
thank you very much to all of you for
being with us on to the point and thanks
to all of you for tuning in see you soon
[Music]
[Music]
you